well in some parts of the country people
risk jail for trying to earn a living
but in other places law enforcement
officers are refusing to play along with
what is so obviously a power grab with
no basis in science Mohave County
Arizona is bigger than the state of
Maryland by territory so far it has had
fewer than 150 Khurana virus cases now
the sheriff says he will not enforce
governor Doug Ducey's draconian stay at
home order sheriff Doug Schuster joins
us tonight sheriff thanks so much for
coming on so you you will not enforce
this why well first of all talk to thank
you for having me I want to be very
clear this is not the country that I
grew up in you know I never thought I'd
see a day where hardworking Americans
are criminalized for trying to make a
living supporting their family we look
at this through the Constitution which
is very clear it's it's obvious to me
that we have a lot of overreach which is
very damaging and according to the
Constitution last time I checked you
know the law of the land in order for a
law to be constitutional it must fairly
apply to all of our citizens equally and
that's not the case out here and so
having said that I made the statement
that I am NOT going to make criminals
out of people who are trying to make a
living and I stand behind that statement
so does Doug Ducey believe your governor
and believe that he has the right to
supersede the Constitution is he explain
this to you I haven't personally spoken
with Governor Ducey I'm sure the man is
doing what he feels is best the concern
I have is you're talking about
guidelines that are coming from the CDC
that are turned into executive orders
which are now being brought into to law
and we're literally making it a crime to
try and make a living and that's
something that I am NOT going to stand
for
why should rules that apply to Maricopa
County which is the most densely
populated county in Arizona applied in
Mohave County which is obviously not
well that's that's the question that's
been asked repeatedly every area is
different based on geographical basis
Mojave County is a very rural County we
are very widespread yeah and a lot of
our county borders up to California Utah
Nevada we continued
you see a large influx of people coming
in join the summer the activities that
Arizona has to offer specifically Mojave
County and yet we're telling our locals
to stay in lockdown and that if they
leave their houses or if they you know
dare go to work there could be criminal
repercussions and the concern I have
Tucker it's very clear in my home town
in Lake Havasu City many businesses are
open while others are being told they
can't even if they choose even if they
elect to operate their private business
adhering to all the safety guidelines
that are in place no one's trying to
downplay kovat the kovat virus we want
everyone to be staying but I think the
American public is smart enough to make
their own choices and decisions at this
point well they are free citizens in a
free country
specially Arizona a great place yeah
amen sheriff great to see you thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much